no headed with a tank round so one of
them is actually a Baroness wait what
the so what's up with the spaceship
you're about to see what's up with the
spaceship this video is sponsored by Ray
Khan stick around to find out how you
can get 15% off a pair of your own hey
guys welcome to visual effects artist
react this is the show where we take a
look at your favorite movie clips and
even me tell you why they're good and
sometimes we tell you they're bad fun
fact this is kind of like how they shot
Lord of the Rings this is how amazing
roto and Bilbo Baggins look so tiny
compared to the big old Gandalf this is
this is special behind-the-scenes
footage of Lord of the Rings guess what
we got some great clips we got some
janky clip so we're gonna look at them
today just take a look at a Russian film
called t-34
isn't that a calculator oh there are
muzzle flashes and these tanks are so
good yeah these are world-class like
slow-mo particles them
[Music]
dude look at that slow-mo bullet what
kind of bullet was that it's a tank
bullet tank bullet oh right in that face
no the head with a tank round what a
fricking head someone wrote this for
Nico because every time we have a chord
or a brainstorming session he's always
like I have an idea we let's follow a
bullet really far from one place to
another all right and this whole movie
is just the back well here's the reason
why I like that shot so much it's
because it's actually a relatively easy
shot to do you just need a way to move a
camera smoothly whether it's on a gimbal
or a Steadicam or it's on a dolly track
or something like that and then you
motion track it and you just put things
that are frozen in the air on the motion
tracking so back in the day we did this
crazy frozen fight scene everything's
like lingering in the air and all we had
to do is have everybody just hold still
and then move the camera through the
scene then later on we tracked it and
added all the debris and the frozen
smoke and stuff like that in the air and
gets a big reaction now the people oh
yeah yeah you're right
look I'm just like freaking out right
now this is crazy yeah
what what this is how it ends finale who
tank's turning their barrels to each
other of course this is the finale you
gotta do it manually I'm just saying
this is the coolest thing ever oh and
it's gonna slide on out that big Stabat
round sparks it's so good barks whoa
they even got those flame geysers coming
out of the choo-choo hole I love the
detail of these shells like liquefying
when they strike objects it's it's
satisfying what sets this movie apart
from everything else are the simulations
of the fire the smoke and the sparks and
the liquid metal fire and smoke and
liquid are like some of the hardest
things you can ask a computer to do and
these guys like let's also do it in slow
motion up close so not only does it have
to be high enough detail to look at at
regular speed needs to be high enough
detail to look good at slow motion this
is probably all done in Houdini which is
the program has good fluid simulations
and good smoke simulations and fire
simulations and spark simulations and
rigid body and cloth and all this stuff
and can do that fall under the same roof
Houdini didn't have very good looking
fire back in the day didn't have very
good looking explosions but they've been
working on it and working on it you just
get all this crazy crazy detail from
having all the systems interact together
I mean the closest thing we have at the
studio for this is like X particles
where you can actually have your an
explosion push an object it's like the
only system we have right now that can
actually go oh well I can sense there's
expanding air in this area so I can
translate that data to some objects on
the ground and have them actually kind
of move in relationship I love how
committed this movie is just the tactics
of a tank fight with this crew it's like
entire 20 minute sequences that are just
a fight do you think world of tanks
funded this I wonder man
we're playing World of Tanks these
people are our only hope
what's the name of the mission Guardians
now we're watching Russian Avengers
we've already reacted to waited
digital's take on the Avengers so now
we're taking our budget from 300 million
and we're scaling it down to 5 million
and also we're going to Russia oh man I
cannot wait
basically this is Russia's top
superheroes fighting baddies this is the
part where they're like all right
Deadpool or no Nightcrawler Plus
Deadpool oh sweet anime I'm digging this
already this is pretty sweet as cool as
this is it kind of ignores the fact that
he would have to get to the same
thickness as a sword to be able to go
through the car oh yeah
how do they film that he starts off on
the left then he's on the right and then
he's on the left again and it's all one
smooth camera shot the whole time the
only real plate is the last one and the
other two because he's midair slash like
away from camera those are probably
gonna be plates I mean that's how I
would do it those first two guys you
never see his feet and I think the thing
that really signifies what's real asanas
look at his hair throughout all of it so
right there you can see not a lot of
detail on the hair you get the big
strands without the tiny strands same
there you get kinda big strands without
the tiny strands and now let's look at
his hair here yeah I can see that really
fine hair detail on top of his head now
he stabs the truck The cuts were already
on the truck as were the swords and he
just comes in and grabs the swords and
they just paint him out for this few
frames before he gets there
all right so one of them is actually a
Baroness wait what the fair man he's a
man there sometimes he's full bare to
which I don't understand why he'd ever
become full bear when he when man bear
does this let's say you have
transformation powers do you ever have
the forethought to maybe take your shirt
off before you transform like or is it
always like you're in such a grave
situation that you're like no time you
shred that garment I think the reason
for that sandwich is that it always
looks cooler to have clothes ripped
apart looks way cooler to have a Clausen
on your bare sim did you see how that
guy folded he's like his legs just like
palpable it looks like we made Marvel
rated-r it's nothing cuz that's an
element that they filmed either
separately or have it in that shop it
needed to be time it and move it
differently the Bears like the Bears not
bad
the bear in Dark Materials looks better
in my opinion I think there's a lot of
CG bears that look better than this bear
but also those bears aren't transforming
into a half man that that transformation
at the beginning though really reminded
me of that werewolf short from love
different robots we got to talk about
love death and robots at some point soon
because we have gotten so many comments
about that and it's amazing so subscribe
if you want to see that in the future
all right so we have ninja
we have bear man there's another one I
haven't introduced you to rock man
and then there's a girl I don't know
what her powers are is that rock man
no that's the bad man bad man gotcha
dude sloth from the Goonies I was like
watching a Bollywood movie yeah this is
very Bollywood
[Applause]
[Music]
the bear takes one punch punch then the
head is down
there's a plane throw my sword at it
giving him ropes in the bear
that's a very Bollywood shot right there
yeah they're not too worried about
physics I hope me so jazzed up if I was
a teenager in Russia and this came out
yeah yeah this is what I think I think
the effects are good enough yeah I agree
they've got some rough edges but they
work they're not really going for photo
realism I think at the end of the day
though it's like you got to get your
movie made and you got to tell your
story and nothing in here is distracting
from the story like when I see the bear
I'm like oh that wasn't really well done
they really should have done better on
that it's like it's CG but I've already
embraced that half this movie CG anyways
like The Avengers for example that's
basically an animated film it's an
animated film with like some human heads
cut out and stuck under the characters
once in a while in like this movie is
entering that same territory where it's
basically just an animated film at least
a good chunk of it you know in order to
really enjoy this movie at all your
suspension of disbelief has to accept
that there's a walking man bear with a
gun turret so it's like so much of this
you've already kind of just tuned out as
not real yeah you're like the animation
spirit it's like okay well what would a
bear fighting a mech really look like
this one is some incredible CG in this
yeah oh yeah I saw the trailer for this
one - that was an edge of tomorrow vibes
from that yeah this is gorgeous
animation
Hey what what what the guys are doing it
that's a really good double right there
that's a really good CG double oh and
then a seamless blend into a person
right there
back to CG double the animation here is
on point by the way do you see how much
like inertia and momentum he carries
with every punch into the ground yeah
and like it moves quick y-yeah
it doesn't feel like it's like lagging
I'm blown away by their detail work with
like all the dust on the ground like
they are like that robot every step is
kicking up a lot of dust and dirt and
debris I mean the thing that really
stands out to me is how seamless they're
coming in and out of the CG doubles of
the guy to like the real-life version of
the guy and well what makes that work is
really good cloth simulation cloth
simulation is tricky because when you're
when you have an animated character
there's a lot of like hidden parts where
the the body intersects with itself so
like if I have a shirt on in a CG
character and I go like this chances are
like my model here and my model here on
my character have slightly intersected
which would make the cloth do an
impossible thing where it pushes into
the character so he gets really tricky
trying to do a good full character cloth
Sims we have you know an over jacket
than a vest and a shirt and then pants
and that it's high and like you have all
these different layers and it also has
to like have the complexity the amount
of wrinkles like if I go like this on my
shirt like there's a lot of wrinkles and
texture and like detail in those
wrinkles you know like to do this to
model this you've got to put a lot of
polygons in my shirt and very often what
you see is like things end up just kind
of ballooning out from the character a
little bit and being too simplified it
almost looks like things are made out of
felt it's like look at how many wrinkles
are in this jacket there look at the
amount of wrinkles and his arms like in
the detail and the wrinkles on his
jacket on the back he has an undershirt
that's also a cloth sim underneath the
suit jacket his pants are cloth sim
everything is simulated it's not just a
static model and then it transitions to
the real actor on the ground in the
foreground boom right there a little
more fright there a little more cut and
then right here back to boom 3d double
right there that's a 3d double it's a
really good three double there's also
there's a breakdown here that's one of
the coolest VFX breakdowns I've ever
seen this VFX breakdown is almost just
as much work as the movie it looks so
good
okay so what's up with the spaceship
dude you're about to see what's up with
the spaceship this is one of the world
class like destruction shots you see
some physics simulations very seasoned
things that turn your computer into a
little crisp burnt piece of toast yeah
it's like the wall okay yeah is that one
thing you've ever seen the shot look at
sound cool I love the color between the
orange and blue it just keeps going oh
look at that bridge destruction stadium
bye oh this is easily on par with
anything coming out of like Hollywood
this is top three world scale
destruction shots of all time so is that
everything we're seeing here is CG the
buildings the everything Chris your old
building generator okay that is Houdini
right there Houdini's great at doing
procedural buildings the thing is like
when you're millions models for
Destruction they have to be built a
certain way for Destruction you can't
just have a cool-looking model and blow
it up the parallels between rigging a
building or like a structure for
demolition really mimics how you would
build it in real life because you need
to build out like the structural
elements whether it's gonna be wood
based or metal base you want to make
sure you kind of have plaster like walls
that break in a certain way is it gonna
Bend when hit or is it gonna shatter
like there's a lot of details you can't
just take a model of a building and
click a few buttons and have it explode
right you need to build it from the
ground up to simulate properly
city say traffic out of the rhythms
divert traffic away they see that the
little a eyes going o avoid this area
like that
how many computer hours would you guess
took to simulate the final assets being
used in that job I'm not talking about
practicing I'm talking about what that
actually was used in the final shot how
many hours of processing power well it's
that's kind of hard to guess because we
don't know how many computers they are
using doesn't matter it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter two computers in our
each one computer two hours same thing
probably like 20 computers each putting
in 100 hours I think it was a lot more
time than that
I'm gonna guess 5,000 hours imagine
hitting simulate on your PC and walking
away for five and then coming back and
seeing that almost a year if we use all
the computers in the studio it'd take a
month this freaking like just throw down
like you want to see a demo reel I'll
show you a mother in demo reel this demo
reels gonna take longer to render than
the final shot so as you guys know
today's sponsor is rake on earbuds and
not only of these things almost half the
price of other leading Bluetooth
wireless earbuds but their latest model
they everyday e25 has six hours of
battery life a ton of bass a very
awesome sleek colorful compact design
and ultra-fast Bluetooth connectivity
I hate when I'm trying to connect them
new tooth stuff to my phone pairing up
pairing you can actually hear that word
over and over again they're gonna work
and also this wireless charging case is
super convenient if you're in the market
for a pair of wireless gear BOTS check
these guys out we have a link in the
description where you get 15% off that's
by Ray Hunt comm slash corridor crew for
15% off your first purchase I don't see
anyone else offering 15% off earbuds
these days so this is an exclusive
thanks for watching everyone remember
we've got a couple other YouTube
channels we'd like you to check out
we've got the corridor cast where we do
our podcast and we also have node where
we play a bunch of games with each other
and have
times both in video games and in
live-action some you can even play at
home too thanks people thanks everyone
for watching see in the next episode